movie thinks she remembered the name in
the goddamn island from the first movie
or give a favorite no Tommy don't wander
off
for God's sake leave her alone Deirdre
stereotypical we're with the top rich
family is stereotypically way over the
top
oh that's Camilla Belle star of 10000 BC
and when a stranger calls damn I guess
being cast as a young girl in a
Spielberg movie doesn't guarantee a life
of drugs and promiscuous sex only a
career of middling films interesting
mother screams about her daughter's
horrifying attack are turned into a
movie editing joke the scientists the
guy on TV
apparently the unbelievable story of
dinosaurs on an island was a big enough
story for everyone on this train to know
about it no one believed this the first
place how did it become a huge story
kids important to the first movie or
given a token cameo in the second one
because this movie has a lot of
gymnastics it needs to get out of its
system that these kids can't possibly
reproduce sight beam was the factory
flaw that was on - 180 miles remember we
braved the animals there a notch of them
for a few months and then move them into
the park yeah no you didn't or else you
wouldn't have had eggs in the land in
the first movie where we got to see them
hatch and whatnot he wouldn't kept on
that Dino DNA on Isla Nublar either yes
the animals won't even know they're
there any lowing strictly observation
and documentation it seems like John
Hammond has never heard of the observer
effect the carnivores are isolated in
the interior of the island so the team
can stay on the Outer Rim don't worry if
I'm not making the same mistakes again
how so no you're making you're making
all new ones
Ian Malcolm would be amazing at cinema
since Eddie who's a field equipment
expert we have a pathologist who I am
not revealing the name of until it's
dramatic enough to do so there we go was
injured
well she's fine she's fine sure she is
let's put the blood-curdling scream from
her mom told us now that I think about
it this whole scene was worthless
we saw some tiny dinosaurs the attack
happened off screen and the parents were
terrible human beings and the girl was
fine I could have gone straight to this
scene and I wouldn't missed it
now it's only a matter of time before
this lost world roll credits
so you went from capitalist to
naturalist in just four years that's
something yes it's gone forced character
development where's the paleontologist
she she came to me I want you to know
this John plays the pronoun game and
Jesus could you just tell him it's
Julianne Moore already your son my
girlfriend to this island alone and it's
amazing how subtly they stuck the
exposition in that line also how she
been gone for days and Ian hasn't
worried about her until now she doesn't
even have Sega chocolate I it's like a
wishes this joke wasn't dated as hell
he's known her for 10 years lighted
Malcolm asked Kelly to come all the way
out here just so he could tell her she's
staying at Karen's place is it so that
she could become a stowaway and find
herself on the island later but anyway
you got your own stuff you got your your
gymnastics competition movie plants the
seed for something awful leader he's
heard too many stories about this island
chain why did he agree to go this far in
the first place a single artists both
photographer and expedition planner guy
seemed surprised by the name of the
island group that Malcolm's daughter
clearly saw on board one of the RV's
when she was stowing away a single
Marcus also Spanish death Island cliche
what does that mean
really you mean you've never been
exposed to basic Spanish your entire
life nice dinosaurs under the picture
because it's not time for the movie to
be dangerous yet
Oh give me a fucking break she didn't
hear any of that the last ten minutes
instead of being surprised by a sudden
other human sara goes straight into
prankster mode and scares the set
another human hilarious
filming camera rewinds at inopportune
time to create dramatic tension cliche
that's why you shoot digital when you go
to dinosaur island people how along
convenience allows air to go on killed
in the movies first 30 minutes because
you said so we can save a ton a special
effects budget by just believing you the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle
Malcolm feels the need to inform
paleontologists Sarah Harding about the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle started
a fire oh I don't know the Donner you
completely forgot about back at the
warehouse for some reason because this
movie needs to prove how bad fathers are
do you see any family resemblance that's
racist no Spielberg loves this parallel
dialogue technique but for some reason
here it doesn't occur naturally enough
and it's annoying as with your parents
that you never showed up for um skipped
I want it up and running in 30 minutes
that's half an hour for those of you
that don't speak English
I guess moody keeps putting in all these
actors who were red hot in the mid-90s
like that's not distracting ashy I love
this guy and his character but damn it's
like the casting director looked at the
list of characters for this movie tried
to narrow it down and finally said I
will choose also god I wish this
could've been the whole movie Kobayashi
hunting down dinosaurs no San Diego
scene just the most dangerous game
Jurassic Park style hey check out this
neat CGI you see that distinctive dome
skull 9 inches a solid bone careful this
guy was inserted in the movie so that he
could Discovery Channel all the
knowledge we need to know no one will be
seated during the Mad Max portion of the
dinosaur movie
wait how did that work you're saying he
shot some kind of gun and it was a wire
with a noose on the end and it landed
perfectly on that thing's neck to be
reeled in
or was that a different gun shooting at
a different animal just slash cut into
this sequence to confuse me this movie
reminds me that the special edition Star
Wars came out the same year and it
pisses me off just thinking about it
Soglin triassic is found by Ross in
Bavaria in 1913 does it kill anybody
dinosaur feels exactly like I do after a
40 minute first act the guy characters
continue to be invisible to everyone
they're openly spying on San Diego is
the perfect set people already associate
how a beautiful city with animal
attractions San Diego Zoo SeaWorld San
Diego Chargers went went super well
organized and well funded Dino capture
endeavor has no one guarding the
captured dinos or even making sure they
don't die and furthermore this board
meeting seems like an incredible time
waster
I know Rowan has his heart set on
bagging a full-size t-rex but engine
currently has a baby t-rex tied up and
ready to go why aren't they already on
the way to say the AYGO is it so that
Nick and Sarah can free the animals and
we can have an island free-for-all for
an hour Triceratops was just let out of
its cage so of course the first thing it
does is crack through Peters tent with a
sense of irony also no one hears a
rumbling Triceratops until it crashes
through the tent as if we couldn't get
enough of that avoided Jeep in a tree
scene from the original Jurassic Park
Steven Spielberg is more than happy to
give us another shot of it how long does
it take for t-rex parents to hear their
child screaming they are fiercely
territorial according to John Hammond
and earlier we heard they wouldn't leave
a baby this age alone for very long so
these t-rexes are being very compliant
with the plot right now we're not alone
on this side something I'm surprised you
didn't realise when all your helicopters
flew right past the big RVs on a cliff
when you first arrived look I get it
these guys are compassionate they want
to help the baby Rex but it's batshit
insane to drag an injured baby Rex
around do you think the t-rex parents
are gonna be thankful hell no they're
not the amount time it would take to
properly heal this baby divided by the
amount of time it would take for the
parents to hunt you down and sideways is
a survival quotient I'm not comfortable
with run a completely different
situation right now
t-rex mom finally gets mad about her
baby missing at the perfect time to
punch Malcolm's words into his stupid
face yeah that phone call probably isn't
in any way important it's not like we're
on an island full of dinosaurs or
anything
there's something pliable that I can go
to save a t-rex machina birds fly away
to signal something ominous cliche now
you're definitely not doing anything
that requires immediate attention and
you're still not answering the phone on
Dino murder Island instead of screaming
t-rex six o'clock Malcolm two science on
the do when I say without question
method so stubborn Sara can waste more
time t-rex is so pissed it went after a
jeep that obviously has no living things
in it and through it because even
dinosaurs know what makes a cool shot
okay now throw my mother outside already
chicks up people time for your survival
earlier when the T Rexes walked casually
into the camp the ground was shaking
under the high hide now that they're
presumably running at full speed no
ground shaking at all Malcolm speaks
only in understated dramatic movie lingo
when screaming is more appropriate also
how could he see that anything bad was
about to happen it's dark rainy and
they're surrounded by trees unnecessary
repetition of unnecessary orders T Rexes
accomplished half their mission and then
just peace out for ten minutes before
returning she survives this just fine
just a little scare I will say this
scene with the trailer hanging over the
cliff from the window that could break
at any moment is pretty rad there are a
couple moments in lost world that are
great and this is one of them three
double cheeseburgers with everything no
onions I might queue all freephone when
the rope goes loose but all three also
catch themselves on the ledge
ya know Jesus these people are basically
cirque de soleil professionals why are
they even worried about dining when
they're basically gymnastic superheroes
seriously
the t-rexes are so hell-bent on revenge
that after pushing the trailer over the
cliff they walked off and then one I
heard some sounds and said hello that
sounds like a truck trying to pull the
trailer back onto the cliff and ran back
to stop it also meanwhile they've left
their defenseless baby on the middle of
the jungle so they can Liam Neeson this
poor bastard okay honey make a wish also
the t-rex is eat the one guy who didn't
really do anything to them somehow the
entirety of two full RVs and a connector
tube falls off and down the cliff in a
way that is perfectly aligned with the
rope these three vehicles were all
apparently 85% gas tank that must have
been some incredible battle between the
hunters and the t-rex's but movie is
better served by not showing it I guess
why they persisted in destroying the
trailers to defend this entire area but
this only occurred to them five minutes
after they were long gone from the area
so they could kill that dude from the
west wing what is the problem well just
train them to be your motorcycle bros
right that hard man jeez ah so Raptor
carnivore pack hunter you know from
Jurassic Park and the Rex's may continue
to track us to faith perceive a threat
to themselves or to their infants no no
you're wrong there dr. hardy mainly
because you're a woman
I mean because my man knowledge is
better I mean damn it how can I put this
into terms her double X chromosomes will
understand taking dinosaurs off this
island is the worst idea in the long sad
history of bad ideas including for the
movie itself but somehow the script
didn't heed that warning hey Carter I'm
going to the ladies room
wait for me yeah okay well I see we
found the guy who trained Stan Lee's
janitor in the amazing spider-man and
the cafe worker and Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows well it was only a
matter of time before the jungle
produced one of those out of nowhere
Hills people always fall down I'm just
surprised it didn't happen as dieter was
running away from the dinosaurs as I
watched this attack I'm quickly reminded
that these little bastards did this very
thing to a little girl at the beginning
of the movie and she lived Carrie miss
diva wait a minute you mean Carter was
only like 10 feet from the rest of the
group
why did none of the other nan headphone
Waring people hear dieter when he was
yelling geez man that guy is right there
it would have taken less time to just
tap him on the shoulder river of blood
is here to tell you that dieter despite
fighting off the copies the first time
and staying
in pretty good shape lost the will to do
so once he jump behind that long and
they worked super quickly this time
kentley always ether crackles in pairs
just so that when you see them sitting
around you'll say to yourself one
crackle is definitely an accident two
crackles well I guess that's on purpose
also do you want ants because this is
how you get ants also you're not on a
damp backyard camping trip you're on the
run from killer dinosaurs who even
decided to pack this in the first place
oh I want to see some dinos don't want
to forget the s'mores now the movies
back to saying every single soft t-rex
step is easily felt and hurt make up
your minds yep a character who earlier
mentioned that the t-rex has a great
nose and might still be tracking them
still has the goddamn t-rex baby black
jacket she's a brilliant lab scientist
but stupid as hell in the field so Nick
took Rowan's gun and put spent
cartridges into it Nick apparently
thinks there's absolutely no reason ever
that you might need to kill one of these
things and is willing to risk lives on
wait a minute is the movie saying after
he tried to kill the t-rex once and
found spent cartridges he suddenly grew
a conscience into science now tranq him
instead or did he not bring any spare
ammo this cave is pretty damn convenient
but more interesting to me is how they
just knew a cave was behind this
waterfall hero character falls down
while running away from evil cliche come
on this guy's so freaked out by a snake
he forgets the t-rex how did this
asshole know they were behind the
waterfall did he see them go in there
did he watch the t-rex eat the Discovery
Channel dude and think maybe my daughter
and girlfriends in there too here's
another great moment in this overall
flawed movie we see the trails of the
Raptors headed toward the hunters a
great visual with great suspense I'm
knocking off another since no one here
is the first three Raptor victims get
victim - this guy is screaming at
nothing until in the next shot a raptor
finally takes mercy on him and eats him
so we scream wouldn't be in vain
I think you saw Jays back crazy that you
spotted it in the tall grass then
assumed it would be important then
recognized in the dark which person you
just met earlier today this bag belongs
to and all the Raptors vacated the area
so our heroes could get through clean
sudden fall slide in a jungle cliche
combined whether they all survive this
double cent sequel takes time during
this suspenseful moment to fellate the
first movie this actually still works
after our hurricane came through it was
attacked by overgrowth endured extreme
heat and four years of non-use seriously
we're still going with that lucky
backpack idea
Raptor simply wants those delicious
graham crackers mm-hmm I don't know this
kind of seems like a really stupid
Raptor to me also Raptor bypasses all
the clear exits from the building to
crash through the last good window
because it has OCD the Raptor who is on
the other side of the truck
it goes blind and simply allows Ian to
run to the shack smart Raptor much like
the audience is so stunned by the
gymnastic turn this movie took it is
dumbfounded what to do when confronted
with it
also on glad her gymnastics could play a
part in the dinosaur fighting that's not
stupid in any way Raptor in fighting
allows air to escape yet again though
I'm not sure what allowed her to survive
that ball from the roof onto her back
whatever it's okay it's over no okay
movie should totally have ended right
there but instead that's once over there
they won't be taken with him because
these two bullets represent the entire
munition supply
they're headed in a portal I can't
reason so this is a decently suspenseful
scene but is the movie telling us that
once the t-rex started is rampaging on
the boat no one sent out a distress
signal somehow nobody thinks it's
worthwhile to evacuate the people in the
dock as a ship approaches at flank speed
also nobody inside this building thinks
it's a good idea to leave right now
except the weaselly nephew this has
always bothered me the t-rex went on a
rampage and managed to eat whoever was
at the ship's wheel without breaking any
windows or opening any doors meanwhile
whoever owned this hand apparently had
the best grip in the world to the point
that his hands stayed on the wheel after
getting eaten whole first off this guy
thinks this is a good idea he seriously
thinks this is a good idea
furthermore the t-rex went on an eating
rampage throughout the boat and yet
somehow he went down into the cargo hold
and a dead guy managed to close the
doors on it
irony t-rex hangs out in San Diego you
ready for the next 15 minutes of the
ship nobody in the neighborhood hears
this how is a chlorine pool a potable
water source for dinosaurs Sarah's still
anthropomorphic anthropomorphic giving
human characteristics to the t-rex
follow the screams cute but San Diego is
a huge city they would actually need
some kind of starting point to even find
the screams bus accidentally foreshadows
blockbuster videos entire corporate
future I don't know if this is racist or
if this homage just reminds me that the
really stupid Godzilla with Matthew
Broderick comes out the following summer
but this is just a sin in my mind
Steven Spielberg stages a scene where
screenwriter David Koepp gets eaten
probably for putting this San Diego shit
in it the t-rex was apparently so
flummoxed back at the factory it's like
a mile behind them after being on their
heels just a second ago here's the movie
switching gears yet again trying to tell
me that these t-rex footsteps on a boat
would not be heard of felt by this guy
Dinah topia dick movie makes a passing
mention of pterodactyls gave 15 minutes
to rampage over San Diego also how do
you keep pterodactyls on the island do
they use those invisible fences or a
LoJack
[Music]
you
one job one day's work very dangerous
it does not expect all of you to live
but those of you who do will have 91
million dollars to divide between you in
any way you see fit the suit cost more
than your education you see this watch
that watch cost more than your car
doesn't even have Sega she's a
troglodyte that gap 230 miles from Dutch
Harbor
on the Cornelia Marie right now hardened
kevlar plates of a titanium tip to try
weave fibrous increase your rate of
climb must go faster I call my agent up
and she says Trent they asked for you
specifically dog wasn't think I don't
know it was it was drugs are bad Jenny
eats something whatever it's happened
[Music]
I'm gonna go out jacking it San Diego